Cáu của tương mề một tổng bị thư tối lâm đại cao quy định của bộ chính chỉ về việc điều động phân công đồng chỉ
bồi thiện miên hoài về việc bộ chính chỉ biết thứ thành quyền,
trường đoàn đại việc có khỏi bỏ mỳ lâm thành của hòa nội,
thôi tham gia bán trước hành bán tưởng buộc thành quy và thôi giữ trước biết thứ thành quy
giệm kỳ hàng nghìn không trong hai nhằm hành nghìn không trong hai nhằm hành nghìn không trong hai nằm hành
nhưng đồng phân công tham gia bán đi thư và chỉ định tham gia bán trước thành bán thử vụ
giữ trước biết thứ đồng quyền mà chạy tổ khó các bạn thấy chú ước
giữ khi thương bán tổ chú chú ước lên bình hương, phó vi thư thương chực đà quy khó hội,
cho tịch quy bán Trung Quốc mặt trận tổ có Việt Nam độ phân chính.
Chú mừng đồng chỉ hồi thiết miên hoài tổng bị thư tối lâm khá nịch.
Đồng chỉ hồi thiết miên hoài là cán bộ chừng thành tưởng cơ sở có nhiều kinh nghiệm trong công tác dân vận đoàn ghét tập hợp và đậm dân dân.
Đồng chỉ cũng tưởng làm trường bán dân bệnh Trung Quốc và trong thời gian được phân công làm bị thư thành quy hà nội.
Đồng chỉ đạo cùng thành quy hà nội và thịt rất sát các nhiệm buộc đật rao.
Tổ bị thư mong muốn đồng quyền mặt trận tổ có các bạn thấy chúng tôi không tích tục đoàn ghét thống nhất của đồng chỉ buổi thiết miên hoài,
khoảng thành giệm buộc trong doàn sắp tới hết rất đặc đề, nhưng cũng rất kể vang.
Phát biểu nhận dịch buộc, tên bị thư đồng quyền mặt trận tổ có các bạn thấy chúng tôi khi biết hoài,
người lời cảm ơn bộ chính trị, bán bi thư, tổ bị thư tổ lâm, các đồng chỉ lãnh đạo đàn nhà nước đạo quan tâm tiên tưởng giáo trọng trách lướng.
Hàng định sẽ tận tâm tận lực, nếu các tiên thành tiên phong cửa bộ, giữ bước miên tất của người phần đạo đoàn ghét thống nhất,
phát biểu chỉ trị tập hệ bán lĩnh sáng tạo, vừa qua mọi khó khăn thách tức để hoàn thành tốt miệm buộc được rao.